hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel if you have
stumbled upon this video there is a very
high probability that you are wondering
about how to get a job in the cloud
computing domain and why won't you the
cloud industry is booming with
opportunities and it allows everyone to
be a part of its growing industry even
for the people with no coding skills Yes
you heard it right even if you don't
have extensive coding skills you can
join as a cloud computing professional
in some of the top Tire product
companies in this video we will discuss
all the nitty-gritty details of how you
can get a head start and an entry-level
job in the cloud computing domain so
without further Ado let's quickly jump
on to the topic but wait to help you
with next step we have our Celtic post
graduate program in cloud computing this
course will help you become an expert in
Azure AWS and gcp and let you master Ki
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud expert
this postgraduate program in cloud
computing help you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementations a cloud computing course
helps you master the core skill sets
required to design and deploy Dynamic
scaling and reliable application on
completion of this course you will gain
Caltech ctme post graduate certification
with 40 plus Hands-On projects along
with opportunity to secure a job in
large companies like Netflix MasterCard
Hobby and more you can check out its
Link in the description box below Cloud
technology is in high demand and
organization are seeking skilled
professionals to manage their Cloud
infrastructure this video will guide you
through the steps to secure an
entry-level Cloud job the first one is
gain fundamental knowledge in that you
to understand Cloud implementation in
detail after that we'll see learn Cloud
platforms and then start networking and
security the first one is understand
cloud computing familiarize yourself
with the Core Concepts of cloud
computing including different deployment
models like public private hybrid more
Concepts like service models like laas
paas and SAS visualization you also have
to learn and Cloud security next we have
learn Cloud platforms focus on popular
Cloud platforms such as Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform gcp start by
understanding their basic offerings
features and services your next step
should be study networking and security
acquire knowledge of networking
fundamentals TCP IB protocols firewalls
load balancing and network security this
knowledge is crucial for cloud related
roles the next step is May build
practical skills the first one in that
is an experience the next one is work on
projects I will tell you them in detail
the third one is obtain certification
now let's see hands-on experience create
a personal cloud lab using free trial
account on platforms like AWS Azure or
gcp practice deploying virtual machines
configuring this networking and security
settings experiment with different
services and get comfortable with their
interfaces the next one is work on
projects undertake personal or open
source project that involves Cloud
Technologies this will provide practical
experience and help you showcase your
skill to potential employers example
could include deploying a web
application on cloud platform or
automating infrastructure the next one
we have obtain certification Cloud
certification demonstrate your expertise
and enhance your credibility start with
entry-level certifications like AWS
certified Cloud petitioner Microsoft
Azure fundamentals or Google Cloud
certified associate Cloud engineer this
certification validate your knowledge
and make your resume stand out Simply
learn also offers Cloud certifications
that can help you land a good job In
This Cloud domain next we will discuss
networking and professional development
in that the first one is join online
communities the next one is attend
meetups and conferences and the third
one is build a professional online
presence let's talk about join online
communities engage with online Cloud
communities and forums such as stack
Overflow participate in discussion ask
questions and learn from experienced
professionals networking with
like-minded individuals can also lead to
a good opportunities next we will see is
attend meetups and conferences attend
local Tech meetups Cloud conferences and
Workshops the these events provides
opportunity to networking with industry
professionals learn about latest trends
and gain insights from experts be
proactive in sharing your knowledge and
connecting with potential employers next
we will see build a professional online
presence create a LinkedIn profile
highlighting your Cloud related skills
projects and certifications share
articles contribute to relevant
communities and connect with
Professionals in this field a strong
online presence can attract attention
for recruiters and increase your chance
of getting noticed next we have job
search and preparation the first step
would be refine your resuming the next
is practice interviewing and apply for
entry level position so how to refine
your resume tailor your resume and
emphasize your Cloud related skills
projects and certification highlight any
relevant work experience internship or
project that demonstrate your
understanding of cloud Technologies next
we have to practice interviewing so
let's see about how to practice
interview prepare for technical
interviews by reviewing common Cloud
related interview questions and practice
sponsors be ready to discuss your
hands-on experience problem solving
abilities and how you have applied Cloud
Technologies to solve real world
challenges next we have apply for entire
level positions search for entry-level
Cloud jobs opening on online job portals
company websites and Professional
Network apply for a position that match
your skill set and career goals
customize your cover letter for each
application showcasing your enthusiasm
for cloud computing and the specific
company you are applying to continue
learning and growth Cloud technology is
constantly involving stay updated with
the latest trends new services and best
practices explore Advanced certification
and proceed a pursuing higher level
cloud roles as you gain experience now
securing an entry-level Cloud job
requires a combination of fundamental
knowledge and practical skills
networking and a proactive approach by
following these steps continuous
learning and demonstrating your passion
for cloud computing you will increase
your chances of Landing an entry-level
Cloud job and kick-start your career in
this exciting field well this was all
about this video on cloud computing I
hope you enjoyed the video and found it
informative please give it a thumbs up
and share it with your friends also if
you have any questions related to this
video then please feel free to ask away
in the comment section below and we will
reach out to you as soon as possible
thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here